let me catch you up on the roger ailes
sexual harassment scandal so that I can
tell you the latest amazing news last
month former Fox News anchor gretchen
carlson filed a lawsuit against Roger
Ailes for sexual harassment and right
after that a whole list of former
colleagues came out with similar stories
weeks later Roger Ailes resigned huge
golden parachute 40 million reportedly
there's currently an internal
investigation being conducted by a law
firm it originally was focused just on
Roger Ailes but after these allegations
continued surfacing from at least 20
women at this point we have news about
that investigation News number one is
the investigation now is also including
other Fox News executives and I don't
think any of us would be surprised if it
turns out that this sort of sexual
harassment boys club scenario extended
beyond just Roger Ailes wouldn't
surprise me I doubt it would surprise
much of our audience the big news is
that there are now discussions of the
audio tapes that allegedly exist that
multiple women have reportedly recorded
in conversation with Roger Ailes we may
have actual audio evidence of many of
what I can only assume are cringed were
cringe-worthy ly embarrassing exchanges
and the settlement discussions that are
now happening reportedly based on
individuals familiar with these
negotiations are growing in terms of the
size of the potential settlements by
some reports up to eight figures because
of the reported existence of these audio
tapes
can you imagine Louis yeah audio tapes
were released of Roger Ailes sexually
harassing and making suggestions about
the exchanges potentially of sexual
favors for positions or raises on Fox
News I can't wait for this stuff to come
out and it's if you if you were in that
workplace and you know this type of
thing is happening why wouldn't you
carry something around with you that you
might use to to catch this this guy in
the act and now we know what that golden
parachute was for it was to help him
with all the settlements well
interesting you're sort of joking but
that's actually true I mean the
negotiations include the idea that Ailes
would personally help to fund part of
the
settlement because you know the sort of
big picture of it is his behavior was so
outside of anything relating to his job
description or what he was supposed to
be doing here and as a result we are now
subject to these lawsuits that Fox News
wants him to personally be funding
whatever settlements are ultimately
reached journalist Gabriel Sherman
recently alleged and it hasn't been
refuted that Fox News already settled
for three point fifteen million dollars
with Lorie loon who is a former Booker
on Fox News that this this is just truly
truly incredible and by the way added to
the list of names we recently heard that
megyn kelly also jumped in and said oh
yeah yeah yeah this is what Roger Ailes
did andrea tantaros who is another Fox
News host that has not been on the air
since April is saying she also was a
victim of Roger Ailes as harassment the
guy still has defenders on the internet
and that's the most amazing thing we saw
it with Bill Cosby we are seeing it with
Roger Ailes and I'm wondering what
what's the big picture there are going
to be some really big settlements here
there's no doubt about that
could this influence how these boys
clubs treat women bigger picture because
you know that in most cases this goes on
at many companies this goes on in many
many places you rarely hear about it
there's a sort of power dynamic where as
we've talked about on the show and spoke
about with Rachel it's very reasonable
to think that victims of this type of
thing women who were victims will just
never come out because they need the job
and they're there supporting their
family or whatever maybe this could
serve to change the dynamic at some
other organizations where this goes on I
don't know I'm sort of trying to find a
silver lining that goes above and beyond
gretchen carlson coming away with
fifteen million bucks yeah this happens
at the smallest of companies and the
biggest of companies and what this will
do is maybe make a few people either
think differently about this type of
behavior right not act on their impulses
or just make them get better at covering
up whatever they do yeah I think the
initial instinct would be how can we
better cover up and make sure we can
continue doing this without
trouble that that's probably the the
most likely outcome of this